video game PR is getting a bit weird
this week first we had Microsoft strange
and slightly mean stunts where they
threw snow at people with the aim of
somehow making other people want to
purchase rise at the Tomb Raider and now
we have Nvidia chucking people out of
planes and telling them to watch TV and
play games instead of you know making
sure they don't die I'm Lucy and this is
your GameSpot news update don't fight
the launch of a new Nvidia shield
Android device this week Nvidia
commissioned professional skydiver Jeff
Provenzano to jump out of an airplane
and play video games as he descended to
the earth from 10,000 feet he drops out
of the airplane with a complete living
room set up which he is attached to at
the right time he ejects from the couch
and the living room falls to the ground
breaking up on impact provenzano and a
cat land safely on the ground and all is
well
apart from the tuber r.i.p to the cat
probably did is actually skydive and
nvidia does note that no animals were
harmed during filming the stunt was
conducted to promote the new Nvidia
shield android TV box which is on sale
now for $200 demarking stunts ever work
on you are you baffled by what this
advert is actually trying to say do you
want to know what happened to sky tuber